[Music]
[Laughter]
you get shamed out of bandicam
actually it lagged so much i'm like you
know i should probably try something
else
and then i'm like this actually works
pretty good
yeah sure maybe betty cam isn't so good
after all
meme review welcome everyone to meme
review
and i'm here with i guess i'm green
pewdiepie again
my hair is green oh [ __ ] welcome back
green pewdiepie we missed you
thank you spadizion in the house
finally you're hosting meme review
hosting i don't know why i call it that
but yeah
yeah i feel like only like elon musk and
like
dr phil have actually hosted meme review
true true i'm not gonna lie i'm a little
out of touch
with the memes lately so i asked time
and this is what he sent
sent me god it's gonna be a bunch of
garbage isn't it
[Laughter]
that's it that's the meme this is what's
life sends you
this is what's i said
oh my god he's like this is the reason
one
uh i checked it's like two weeks old but
okay recent banger okay
i saw this and i'm like people always
flake on like old memes
people that use old memes but i'm like
new ones aren't always good either okay
this is just a troll face yeah yeah is
that germa
it is germa yeah it's some streamer i
don't know who he is
i did like this one though oh the
pelicans so smoothly
dothi crest a wind gun
that's pretty nice that's pretty good
that's pretty good i am a fan of the
the memes that chop up letters to
just have a sentence in them for
beautiful poetry
and then we also have the keanu reeves
version
what is the face what is happening i
don't know apparently troll face is back
i'm so confused oh on face app i just
feel old
wake the [ __ ] up crew mate we've got an
imposter to eject
hey that's pretty good okay this is
cringe this is crazy
yeah yeah you're welcome should we just
write a zero and move one
uh give it a one i feel bad doing a zero
somebody out there is like laughing at
this and i don't want to [ __ ] all the
way don't pick the moral high ground
over me i'll rate it at two then
okay we'll just keep going until it's at
10. the best meme ever on meme review
it's so good not cringe
okay let's move on to my favorite memes
as of late which is cyberpunk memes
yeah are they are the memes gonna be
finished
are their memes gonna have bugs in them
yeah it's gonna be it's basically us
reacting to glitches
[Laughter]
let's start let's start off with the
memes i really like this one
have you seen it have you seen the kid
eat a burger for like
he never stops and he's there yeah you
notice it too
there's so many of them i had a guy eat
a burger and it's just like every time
you want to take a bite it vanished out
of his hand
it was like schrodinger's burger every
time he looked at it it just disappeared
that's not what schrodinger is it's a
quantum burger
it's a quantum burger it looks
radioactive too so it makes sense
yeah that's true and that keyboard jesus
christ
futures now in the future we will have
no letters on the keyboard
you just imagine the burger oh man
takamura
i always feel bad when i just leave them
hanging there but i guess yeah
his head is in his chest he can just
keep eating the burger
he's fine yeah it never ends oh yeah i
even noticed
the smoke yeah they only yeah they
always do that
posing that's funny beautiful
i like the glitches in the game what can
i say they enhanced the experience
i have just made it like too boring and
too plain otherwise
it's like what do i want just edgy
cringy dialogue
true that's all you get otherwise please
never fix the game cyberpunk
leave it like skate 3 or something it'll
be a classic
really enjoying cyberpunk so far i'm
glad well some people are enjoying it
yeah bro you forgot to turn rtx on oh
grande
ah what a jokester oh
this is this is just sad it's like
watching a wedding video after your
divorce
oh no oh god what we expected
i really wanted half naked lady
in the street yeah what i got
was kiana reeves that's a win yeah it's
a
it's a shame his character is so sh in
the game how did you make me hate keanu
reeves
only cyberpunk this
this is the combat you got it the combat
in cyberpunk
summarize oh that's my stock images
it really does feel like as an asthmatic
i really appreciate the inhaler
appreciation in cyberpunk the
representation for inhalers
finally there's representation for us
every time i get shot in the game i'm
just like oh hold on
okay let's go that's why the oldest got
a carrying one on hand
in case you get shot right her outfit
needs to be weirder though
that's true it's a bit too too she's too
normal looking i had a character in the
game
everybody else is wearing like neon and
see-through and everyone's in their
underwear and wearing and has
man buns in the game and then one person
in the middle of a club was wearing like
just dungarees or something and they
looked so normal it really threw me off
what's dungarees like overalls oh
you don't belong here what the [ __ ] they
just they look like they worked at
wendy's
the future it's such a special game it
truly is
so they made this tweet oh do you have a
kazooie
i have a i have a mouth herp oh [ __ ]
[Music]
there's no way around
okay do it do it again okay i can see
you you know
wait i'll play it on my nose as well
ow that [ __ ] hurts
i'm done i'm done i'm over it okay so
cyber [ __ ] memes yeah
yeah they tweeted in 2018 the whole game
is going to
be a meme so at least you know they
didn't lie oh
that's true they predicted it we got
what they said
this is before the dark times and the
long long ago
poor cyberpunk everyone worked so hard
on the game for over a decade
almost a decade no one gives a and
maybe maybe they can have like a no
man's sky
thing where they that's true yeah be the
hero
customize your genitals me and my best
that's a charge right there yeah i'm
waiting for this patch to happen
basically
secret handshake a cdpr release is a
boogie open world rpg
god no what sorry force of heaven
oh todd suddenly skyrim not so bad huh
cyberpunk that skyrim release again
maybe yeah
is skyrim out on ps5 oh my god it has to
be right
if it isn't it's gonna be a prom it's
probably just backwards compatibility
they're like it's fine
that doesn't count thank you todd let's
get into the
the real stuff yeah this is my favorite
part of the game just that have you seen
this
no okay
oh no
[Laughter]
good game can you do that can i just
upgrade my
strength set this is the point where i
don't understand if it's a good
hope it's not i want to be able to do
that i love doing that
i want to just punch everybody around
that's what makes it more fun
i like the npc just like yeah i'm going
in the car
yeah i'm going in the back seat of this
vehicle there's something about the game
though every time you do anything in it
and people either react over the top or
they don't react at all i was in a
shooting range yeah and i was shooting
the targets and everyone outside freaked
out
i'm like oh my god oh my god
they should have gone cop teleports
behind you
oh yeah they teleport you've seen this
one right oh yeah
classic where's my car
oh is this game worth it uh
is that a good question
oh that's good yeah perfectly timed
charlie he's everywhere god bless him
speaking of everywhere
i have one of you oh no hair yeah
we talked about this clip it's it's so
funny are you losing
hi what a face you have okay i'll come
out and come back in you come up with a
better line
hi are you lizzy guess my dead sponge
[Music]
catch my stance she has two lines and
that's it that's it yeah and they just
repeat themselves
oh but they're so different what does
she say oh my
what a sweet kiss my dead bun
okay it caught you in a bad day i guess
oh
classic oh man yeah it's a good game
it's so
it's so bad why would you want it to be
more serious that's
that's funny yeah i assure you this but
it's funny
i just backed up the car in the middle
of the
what the road are you doing i'm driving
here
oh i cut it off though no it's perfectly
cut scream
the whole section of that was
it hilarious kept going and then the
whole thing [ __ ] exploded oh yeah
you're right
what wait is this somebody taking your
clip
putting it on tick tock and then sive is
taking it and putting it on twitter
and now it's a meme review oh
that's the same economy right there yeah
they're just out here farming karma
let's do some more this is good
oh that's good nice oh drinking josh
what a weird game have you seen this
oh that's good
such advanced ai how did they pull it up
dude it's the future honestly if they
just came out and
memed it's the future anything is
possible i would be on board with them
yeah they could turn this around that
yeah that's a good point just embrace
the memes
mm-hmm we meant we meant for this we
thought about this
yeah someone's gonna find that easter
egg
[Applause]
so this person got his camera stuck
behind the car
so he automatically could see himself in
third person
[Applause]
no
[Laughter]
oh
hey oh classic
oh god that's what i've been doing
running around that's uh
night city that's why everyone keeps
reacting like crazy people when you do
anything it actually makes sense now
yeah you know what i will kiss your tits
kiss my teeth man jumping out of the car
211 miles an hour
i have not seen this and either oh yeah
nothing bad could happen right
cyberpunk best game
60. seven years the compilations of
people being like this is gta 4
back in like 2011 or whatever it came
out that's like you bounce in the car
and you'd fly for ages and your
character would ragdoll everywhere and
then like
cyberpunk 2077. it's just like contrast
yeah
there you go there you go honestly i
would prefer this
it gets me back into the game quicker it
doesn't waste my time it doesn't waste
time
it's a feature it's not a bug you should
just trademark
bugs and then your game is revolutionary
okay
here we go
this is what you said when everyone
reacts
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you cyberpunk that's that's a cool
reference i don't think a lot of people
of course now i have to show you one
maybe it's in here somewhere
yeah you've probably seen it i think it
has is this uh
dolan's more people no it's someone
else's line than anywhere else
oh it looks so good
it's so annoying and it crashes
it really is like this guy isn't it yeah
yeah
in some ways it's worse this is the
first time a triple a game has been
taken off
the playstation store i think damn i
and the xbox store all at the same time
hey imagine not having a playstation 5
ps4
you're certified bug free bug free
[ __ ] victor not bad i don't know what to
say
take this and remember the joke
[Laughter]
oh my god it's a bug free game certified
jesus how does nobody catch this
have you had the one where you're like
driving down the street too fast and
your character t
poses out of the car no oh my god that
sounds amazing
as you just drive your character like t
poses and then parts of you like
go back into the car and all that's left
is like your head at one point
it's like how did how did that get
through how does nobody drive cars in
play testing i don't get it
the the thing is like it's not like it's
buggy just for some people
for everyone that plays the game gets
these glitches
constantly they must have they must have
known
for debs
getting caught
[Music]
dude the hype was so hard for this game
yeah it's a shame
we're gonna have keanu oh wait keanu's a
fidget fidgeting
shut up negligible i can say it all
right fidget
it's a fidget on my imagine is it fidget
sigmund figment
anything to be fair that's a weird word
i don't blame you
okay thank you why is it just in my head
they can be my head in real life this is
super lame dude
[Applause]
he was already in my head i saw him
everywhere i went already yeah i don't
need to play
a game for at least ridiculous yes
stupid pay 60 bucks for keanu in my head
at least he does say impressive [ __ ] in
the game oh he does
he does do that you're right oh i've
seen this one all right
just a couple this is oh
this is just what it's like to play it
an absolute perfect storm
this should have been the gameplay they
showed when they hit the first
i've done brand deals where i've had
characters like glitch out and
go up and bounce all over the place and
they're like no please cut that out i'm
like no everyone will love this i swear
yeah you're right
whose head explodes
oh and then of course there's a sexual
ad in the background because that's what
the future is
a bunch of stuff everything is sexual
you want soda which hole do you want to
go in
all right maybe future not so bad no you
can't enjoy the game
other people hate it yeah these are
everywhere
oh they were sending a sign
they were trying to tell us something i
still like the game i got a good kick
out of it i enjoyed what it was
yeah yeah it was never going to meet the
hype anyway yeah it's way more broken
than i thought though
yeah for sure
hey and this is the thing assassin's
creed unity now
on xbox series x runs really well and is
amazing
i played it like a month ago start to
finish just give it
six years and cyberpunk will be right
there can't wait to play cyberpunk in
2077 and it will run really
well oh
good good relevant memes all right
cyberpunk memes
what's the consensus uh i'll give it a
7.
kind of what i would have given the game
you know oh i'll get i'll give it an a i
think the memes are better than the game
okay okay hot take
did we do the the client thanks man
next meme i'm new here i don't know how
to do it i only know how to
imitate you but go to the next meet bros
okay wait that's that's old yeah that's
true we don't do that anymore okay
we got oh yeah you've probably seen
these right
oh yeah i saw your one they don't know i
have 100 furnaces
in minecraft what would be your
equivalent i tried to find one
where your fans made one but i couldn't
find it they don't know i did 100
episodes of happy wheels
that's good that's good they don't know
i have four bells in my house
do you have four yeah not bro i thought
the bell meme was like
i thought the economy was going like
boom for a while invested in the bells
i guess yeah i thought i thought it was
going to be like tambourine economy
i didn't really like push it as hard
maybe it's still boom this is just a
start you got four stay on
no mouth hurt
that's not what they're called they're
called a harmonica aren't they
well when i looked it up it was called a
jaws
no that's a harmonica what is it called
i don't want to say the actual name
medieval heart that's that's an irish
harp that's
the symbol of ireland is a harp really
yeah it's on our money
that's the the symbol for guinness is a
harp oh [ __ ]
you're right i didn't know that history
lesson on uh mean review how about that
yeah and i have a shamrock on my
cup for top of the morning coffee please
buy it now the shameless plug
sorry well thank you for coming on me
and ruby it's been great
don't cut that don't come out i'll come
here outside
with what a harmonica not my top of the
morning cup
anyway anyway they don't know i'm good
at speed running more
64. if only honestly i would be
really upset if people didn't know i had
that talent and they were all over here
dancing
such a useless talent i love it
but all these speed runners on twitch
are dying right now
i get i get that it's super difficult
and takes a lot of skill but this
yeah compared to all right anyway next
i figured you would like this one oh do
i have to do the voice you have to do
the voice
this is the best party ever monsters and
humans co-existing
everyone is so nice i'm hungry
that's cute they don't know about the
dilemma i'm facing right now
obviously you run over the girl right
yeah that is always my
everyone's like well what if the people
on the other side are all criminals and
that person's a doctor
like okay yeah sure it's
still like killing people two seconds to
live anyway
what if that person uh after getting
saved by train guy hit by care
what if that person saved my train grows
up and become a real evil and kill
everybody
yeah what if we actually like save what
if we go back in time and
like kill the right people i like this
one because it actually looks like
oh it's so cold
might be tart well we there was no
killing start
so does everybody else george i i like
this because he's clearly contract
contracted contractually obligated to be
there
yeah poor george he's working on the
next fromsoft game
as well oh that's cool he's helping them
write it the original one someone found
the medieval version
dancing is too jaunty my feet hurt i'm
hungry
this is like this is ireland parties
this is 100
this is ireland still today it's a bunch
of people out in the field
all you need is a couple of cows and
sheep in the background it's a party
it's officially a party
nice as a as a cat owner now
i can confirm this is 100 true 100 true
uh
they do go meow and then sometimes
they don't even know that i'm hungry i
like this one because it's the uh
the reverse one okay i wish i was at the
front partying with friends
this game is oh bad
the chicks are ugly there's no alcohol
this is the parties i wish i went to
when i oh yeah yeah we never did stuff
like this everyone just partied and had
fun and [ __ ]
what what's your ideal party he's
playing guitar hero
sports honestly yeah yeah whenever
there was a you know in this party you
go into that one room people playing
guitar yeah
i'm there oh yeah i actually was at
parties like that in college everyone
would be in the kitchen
like drinking and congregating and
kissing and what not in the corners
and then it was that one roommate who
hated his roommates having a party
so he was just in his room playing wow i
was like honestly i kind of feel you bro
i'm just here because i am 20 and i need
the cultural clout
and respect exactly yeah yeah
yeah that's literally it i need the
social social points to be here but i
don't want to participate
yeah i don't want to be the odd one out
i can't wait too much about what
these people think about me oh god we
are we are actually the meme
they don't know i have a mildly
successful youtube channel
they don't know i have videos to upload
tomorrow oh my god i did that as well
holy sh what i because i went to college
twice i dropped out the first time and
then the second time
was when i started youtube but during
that when i graduated
i didn't go to my graduation because i
was too busy doing youtube videos oh
[ __ ]
and then everybody asked me to go out
drinking that night to celebrate and i
was like
they don't know that i have youtube
videos to make
oh my god i was the meme well if you
since you admitted it i can admit it too
i think that it is a relatable meme
because like you want to feel like
you're someone at a party right
yeah it feels a bit cringe to me but i
used to be super into graphic design
and i felt like i i remember apartment
like
i know how to magic one in photoshop
but that's the thing it's like now look
at you now look at us we're
doing what we do we're successfully yeah
they don't know they do know jack those
two videos i did while i didn't go to my
graduation
is exactly why i'm here today hell yeah
the sacrifices we made
yeah i'm glad we did this me yeah
what are you what are you reading 10 out
of 10. 10 out of 10
10 out of 10. all right that that's me i
can relate to this meme
i can relate to it too i'm glad it's one
of those that come back
let's get let's give it in you'll all
feel it someday
nine nine okay
okay jack next meme next
okay now we got into the real
nitty-gritty
okay we got the these are just
icebreakers
irish memes [ __ ]
irish memes irish memes
alert alerts let's go
i want like my equivalent of halo free
oh no free dude that's what i try to
find there there is none there is none
most of these are just like i'm confused
so now i can ask jack about it but
somebody
somewhere good i like this one let's
post italian memes so marzia
you have to do this ear farmage maverick
martini or pewdiepie jacksepticeye
what the [ __ ] is this that's not a
language
i don't speak irish what the air fight
mean
people make fun of swedish all the time
what the hell is eggs
try to read that second word in the
yellow meibrai
it's mavery mavery maybe like the name
avery
yeah the name maeve is spelled like that
what are they r-a-i at the end
that's amazing it's
i don't speak gaelic
i took 12 years of it in school and
still can't speak it did you really
yeah we had to do like oral exams and
everything in it and i had no idea what
i was saying
it's only it's only really spoken in
like the west of ireland now
by so few people that thanks england for
uh dominating us for 800 years
destroying our language but it's just
nobody's stupid in it
nobody speaks it so i i don't get to
practice it
dead meme dead meme dead meme i'm sure
somebody in the comments can translate
it for me okay so because i was hoping
you would
translate this because i don't
understand okay give me your best shot
at it oh christ will you look at
darwashte
awata christ will you look at the waste
of water
you knew seven years was worth it dude
this isn't gaelic this is just an irish
accent wow you speak gay look so
good wow a waste of water
i wish the water oh wait here's the skin
fantastic
oh that baby's name has to be like
sheamus or paddy or something
it looks like he's about to pull you you
want a guinness
that's a british accent sorry you want
to get his mic
oh my god he looks like he's either 50
or 5 years old
it's amazing i love it
it's so horrible and wonderful to look
at at the same time i love his little
outfit he's so
cute oh that's a loud you could have a
grand old paint in the chat with
yeah can you tell anything any problems
you have to
yeah he'd keep you in after the pub
calls he he do
lock in with you no lock down he'll
he'll let you go finish here
meanwhile in ireland accurate absolutely
accurate
this is literally what you said before
yeah
i said this in my tour as a joke
that where i lived was next to the
oldest bar in europe
yeah which is called shawn's bar from
the year 900
so it's like it's really [ __ ] old and
it's still there today and the river
it's the biggest river in ireland
flooded next to it
so people would just go down with their
welly boots on like this
oh my god have pints outside is that
even a meme
it's accurate madness stop the bites
from having a few pines if you just put
on your pair of boots mate
oh go get squatter lads that guy on the
far left
i feel like i've met him and you know
that they're talking about
nothing they've been there all day and
they haven't gotten a single sentence
they have nothing to share
did you guys have have that because i
know it's a big thing here and in
ireland did you guys have
i'm assuming you have pubs in sweden
like bars that people can go to i'm
honestly like
it's usually a restaurant that has a bar
it's that's it i've never seen like an
actual bar
it's not on nightclubs yeah because here
you have like pubs that people go to but
it seems like all the retired men
just go to these pubs and drink all day
yep that's
when all day they go home and then they
come back the next day and do it all
over again
i don't know if that's specific to here
and maybe australia but
it's so bizarre i don't understand it
that's retirement you
i hear they go really early too like in
the morning they'll they'll go
yeah midday pop opens and they're gone
yeah
and that's what i thought my future was
gonna be when i was a kid i was like god
i gotta do something else with my life
dude retirement is gonna be awesome for
us we have all these games to play
dude i can finally spend him 16 years
playing red dead
yeah i'm gonna play i'm gonna be wow
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome yeah
dude in retirement we should play wild
together i've never played oh yeah
oh hell yeah all right i'll see you in
hell yeah irish yoga oh god
hey my cha can't do that
yeah that's that's the next level irish
did it first irish did it first
oh my god yeah again it's just sad
i've seen this i feel like i've seen so
many people like this
who are just absolutely [ __ ] and this
is like like two o'clock in the day
and they spent all day forgetting the
rest of it all right meanwhile in
ireland
accurate ah sure
[Music]
accurate
well it actually is ireland so yeah
all right [ __ ] irish people want to
hear a joke who's more irish than the
irish
americans oh my god yes americans please
stop okay good because i wanted to ask
you about this because i it annoys me
too
you've seen this happen even around me
yeah yeah yeah yeah
every time i go every time or we went to
like a maker thing or something like
where ireland are you from because like
my family are from there i'm like it's
not going to be cork dublin or galway so
there's no point telling you
and then i'm like i'm from awfully like
what oh cool yeah my whole family's from
cork
it's like yeah [ __ ] great thank you i
was like yeah so we're like
we're like irish as well we're not we're
like totally the same
like oh my god i mean so much in common
my husband's grandfather's dog was from
johnny gall
so like that makes us i can wear green
on paddy's day but then i'll call it
patty's day and get it all wrong
i get it americans you want to feel
special but shut up just shut up stop it
yeah they do this with italian too
they're like i'm totally italian
yeah i don't know why it's certain
cultures people do it with it's like
irish
italian yeah maybe a little bit of
british as well but
they're so proud saying that they're
from ireland and then irish people are
like
yeah whatever even we're not this proud
of someone should be
proud no one should be proud americans
are bigger irish patriots than we are
it's funny though only in ireland the
president huge for the atm
why wouldn't he there get out of the
bloody way
i'm depressed this is i feel like this
is more of a european
thing yeah i think so too yeah there's a
lot of times
you see stuff like this and like oh an
american made this meme i can tell
bloody stupid stupid americans in it
i don't get this one so i'm glad i'm
you're here
what if a couple of negan's won't be
grounded what does that mean
what does that mean okay
everything people always say everything
in ireland will be grand like
you could lose like it'll be fine you'll
be great you're [ __ ] it'll be grand i
even have a
a magnet on my cooker that says for fake
and it'll be grand
excuse me no matter what happens we'll
get through it it'll be all right
but what if if a couple of naggings
won't be great
a negan is like did you guys have those
like a little bottle of vodka
oh yeah yeah i know what it is yeah yeah
it's not like a full big bottle and it's
not like the mini ones it's like
between one oh then i don't know but
yeah okay for some reason we call that a
nagging i don't know why it's called
that
so you go out and you drink a nag in a
vodka
when you go out with your friends you
start off the night with a night in a
vodka because you'd be
too poor in college to afford anything
else
i know which one you mean and you're
drunk for the whole night yeah yeah yeah
no that one that would forget it went up
it was yeah
but that's a good meme i like that one
i'm glad you liked it how people react
when i tell them i'm irish and you can
tell me if this is anchoring that's nice
okay are you drunk right now they're
people do people make that joke does
that ever happen
uh yeah they just say drunk jokes
constantly
that's hilarious is that why your accent
is funny because you're all drunk
uh i'm guessing you see a lot of
leprechauns
then how come you're not changed
[ __ ] off okay go [ __ ] yourself the rest
of the world
we were voted sexiest accent in the
world many times
all right i read above italy above
french
yeah you can look it up it's a fact
google it
oh spanish and irish okay it's maybe not
for 2020 but we were voted
one of the years irish accent voted the
sexiest accent in the world
2019. let's go okay can you read uh can
you read this again
[Music]
uh oh discord stop working that's weird
look it's the irish accent was voted not
gaelic language
okay fire it up oh we gotta rate it
that's a ten that was hilarious i love
that okay
take good irish meme gets a tandem meme
review history
made history being made
anyway jacksepticeye memes next meme
okay i kind of snuck myself in here so
we can address this
i kept memeing about my ladder on my
subreddit and there everyone was like
oh my god i think next door to each
other i actually bought that same ladder
because of your recommendation because
it's so amazing
it's great yeah we're going to the moon
baby
telescopic ladders that's a collab
waiting to happen
yeah no i shaved your neighbor's ladder
on my subreddit ah
because of how shitty it was it was like
a fold out ladder yeah it wasn't even 30
meters
dude i had your ladder i couldn't use
that but i used the
neighbor's ladder because i didn't want
to die it's so wiggly if you go on time
right right right yeah says says a
coward
all right another thing to address
[Applause]
your homework sure bro don't make it too
obvious i won't bro
this happened yeah and people need to
realize
that we do this on purpose so many times
you've done this with my thumbnails as
well that's true
and it's just like sometimes you're just
too lazy to make a thumbnail and
somebody else already made the one
you're going to make anyways
like i'm not good i'll just put my face
over his
yeah we're not original stop stop
pulling us to anything else
okay
oh god it's too real
it's too real i can't you know what i
we have diversity to us there's two
sides to us yeah sometimes you got
like you gotta let the child start to
play every now and then
that's right but you also got a show
you're you have some [ __ ] to [ __ ]
around with yeah yeah i'm just not all
top of the morning oh
ding ding ding i like how you became is
that beyonce
yeah oh yeah you got to be cause you got
nice legs you do well you get to be paul
rudd i would much rather be paul rudd
than beyonce
all right well that's a hot take if i
ever heard one oh yeah
look i tried to dye my hair at home it
didn't turn out as green as me
or you did it correctly no i'm so
confused
it just looks like yourself
that's that's good i like that one it's
taken for your subreddit so you'll
probably have to react to it twice now
me posting an arch except okay it can't
be that easy
it is that easy look every subreddit has
their inside jokes
come on people post a [ __ ] tambourine
in yours and it's like oh my
god that's so funny
i get it please don't forget
please don't forget okay oh yeah you're
dating dope and smurf's daughter
i uh sure i've never watched phineas and
ferb
see you went from what does this mean to
be like
oh my god dude okay just know this is
hilarious
basically okay that's good dude she's
hot
what can i say yeah this is a girl you
reacted to this one already
what happened jake how did this have
many talents where did this go
jack and sean and jack's have to go you
can't put jack and jacksepticeye
in that's just now you're just looking
to fill space no no
no that's fair that's fair okay sp dicey
came from
you on your channel and maybe for jesus
green pewdiepie came from jesus well we
talked about green pewdiepie and then
everyone was like
green pewdiepie green pewdiepie it was
like yeah
did the joke that's so cool toss boy
classic
stinky that's just truth
i'm a man of many talents i respect it
i respect this my
oh there it is now we're reacting to it
again
it's [ __ ] great though it's so good
there's like a couple of sections where
it just looks too
good yeah yeah it just says
[Laughter]
i love it i love that you look very
similar it's so weird
oh my god i love you
that was nice for you to do jack i just
care about my fans so much
oh no you've seen these right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey
oh it's like that picture where somebody
put my face on her face for your wedding
photo now
we're about to get married beautiful so
why don't we do a test that's what marty
looks like with facial hair
we are completely like people to get
married or not we are compatible to get
married
i don't know why i say it like they're
sponsoring it
all they can see is billy irish now what
are your thoughts i'm gonna leave it
there
yeah yeah yeah all right that was
jacksepticeye memes obviously
a five review a five okay i'm just
kidding
it's a ten of course of course this is
everything people wanted to be or is
this the cyberpunk 2077 of meme reviews
the hype is so high for jacksepticeye
no i had a great time that's good okay
all right well
subscribe to jack if you haven't already
for some reason
subscribe to pewdiepie if you haven't
did you just subscribe to me right now
no i hit the bell i didn't hit the bell
before
no you're even a member on my channel
well you're
you remember my of course yeah i don't
have anything for you to watch
because i get access to unique
jacksepticeye modes
uh yep uh-huh and nothing else
[Laughter]
look at graph that's it look at graph 18
not subscribed wrong with you that's way
too high